The first part of our return value is just the word function.
This is to separate it from a number like 3 or 4
and to allow us to tell if the user mistakenly tries to call something
that's not a function later.
We then list the parameters which we got right from the abstract syntax tree,
the body of the function, which we also got right from the abstract syntax tree,
and the environment in which it was defined--this one, env.
And we're passing in env here instead of some global environment or whatnot
and this is what's going to allow local functions to see local variables.
This is why things like makegreeter work.
They can refer back to variables that were currently in scope
when they were defined.
Many of you may notice a striking similarity between this and our previous code
for handling function declarations.
In fact, our previous code just had 1 more step
where we added this value to the environment.
For an anonymous function, we don't add it to the environment
unless the user assigns it.
But this code should look really, really familiar.
We have something almost exactly like it for handling functions at the top level
as JavaScript elements.